how's God rest but a beer to pass um
welcome back to mad father I I said I
was gonna do that I other ending because
I hated the other one so basically what
you gotta do is I heard you bro saying
this but I felt like wait there's
something on a different sketch the room
came I felt like I wanted to get the
ending that I would get if I just [ __ ]
playing it the way I what felt like
playing it so you get the room key this
goes is like come here come here but I
already knew instantly which room if you
remember in the archives do you remember
haha you are smart as you are fluffy
just kidding not okay what that was you
what those are room there with with a
bunch of question marks or what what in
[ __ ] so the first things gadlin's go
over die like a door been open if kids
you're not stupid
nothing wrong with being away I probably
would have it um I think I was trying to
say something think it was trying to get
me into this room a bed here come on
she's six man you're sick I found a
diary could this be Maria's diary Yes
Doctor
it has been a year to the day since I
came to this met sure I will never
forget that day keep [ __ ] burping
I like this son track team whatever
please thud beautiful fun somebody
thought somebody Wow
times are bad huh uh bum she could be a
fine subject with some work it's pitiful
to see one so skinny
come to me my humble ease I'll give you
clothes and delicious meals that bastard
learns the man just to kill them nom nom
nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom
nom nom nom nom nom nom de dafuq nom nom
stay here for a little while I'll tell
my family about you family I have a wife
and a girl turning seven so she has sex
all right I'm sure they would welcome
you family
why does she uh oh look what the hell is
this person like me oof look what awful
injuries it must hurt
perhaps I could do something ha ha
Joseph I'm such a good vibes actor it's
incredible
my skirt won't be enough claw but the
only other class I have is Sochi how is
she helped out him and then he realized
he could use her is that it hmm I'm
surprised he would about to die but he
recovered overnight it seems he was
given excellent treatment as it making a
[ __ ] sense it's not like he had
anything better to do
did you treat him yes how handy they're
exceptionally talented please I
I couldn't let this go to waste
what's your name ah I am um Maria Maria
hmm an appropriate name my I would be my
assistant
ah I do not wish to lose you please stay
with me it's faith Maria well will you
trust me with the rest of your life yes
but that doesn't make any sense that she
would like help him kill people I was so
happy so happy it saved me that was
alone but you made me need it you gave
me love all right fine there we go
as long as I'm needed I will stay with
you how would I live without you I love
you doctor well I'll be damned
I'll be damned [ __ ] up family man
[ __ ] up triple die I never really knew
anything about Maria after all Maria
must really love father too
Wow that crazy son of a [ __ ] has a lot
of [ __ ] if you know what I mean all
right Bryce so now I will have the
privilege of playing half the game by
myself and oh sure alleged I know you're
gone and that nice farty Hannah bad dad
ah so now I will have the pleasure to
replay these five minutes and half of
the game by myself damn it why did I
save on crook all right here we are
again at the ending by the crystal
diamond thing this is a storybook world
better move on
sorry I never noticed that before
alright let's see how this ends Shelby
buzzes what is this mr. yeah we know
that what not yeah [ __ ] god [ __ ] [ __ ]
on my duck scene second breast air we
are again back this to where we get to
choose say father a grad mom swish which
one should i Ches say father
all right now I'm just kidding we got a
grand mom's wish to get the other ending
hopefully it'll work I might have to
kill a Salman if this doesn't work I'm
sorry Mahathir mom she loves you more
than anyone I can't take your way away
from mom I I'm sorry
ah well I told God
well that means again did a quick quick
I wanted to hear more of that all right
so did you get the flash back again or
where am I
did I make it back I thought Maria would
save us it's just me we will find her
body now probably I feel like I'm
getting a different ending than the one
I'm supposed to get oh it's all blood oh
that's good that's kind of nasty man
croakin what's up I'll get it not gonna
save over the real save file croc hood
out of my way croc good what's going on
but uh Maria hmm I was having my midday
nap where is this mistress where's the
doctor what happened to it
mistress the doctor they're dead no hey
no dr. Jones dr. Pat's Pat's wake up now
dr. Peretz bill
all right it's so quiet the cars must
have faded and fathers gone I'm sure
this is for the best
no one will ever hurt be hurt by
father's inspire many more I'd say the
same thing mom but now what do I do
I don't have a father or mother I'm
alone you are alone no I shouldn't say
that
I have Maria after all I have to live
alone from now what about Maria Maria
why will you do you can't just stay here
this phone's going triple dutch but if
you have nowhere to go then go with her
but how dare she bitch-slapped me
No
what the [ __ ] this is not what Maria
yeah
doctor you're no luck you are with us no
longer but please take heart I should
take up what the future you wish for the
mistress I shall see it out so please
rest in peace [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I did it
wrong somewhere along let's grant let's
say father this time around and see if
that will change anything at all oh [ __ ]
ah doctor Maria what did I do
so much blood sir anything I could use
so I can help her
no can I there's something any there so
I will okay this is different
did I do this last time so I remember
myself do wonderful at damn bro a
bandage
well I can't wrap this around your
clothes lifter Scout up a little bit
hello this is telling something else
that's wrong she's six sorry about that
this should help stop the blood mister
thank you for caring for me it's fine
don't worry about it I should be most
loathsome in your eyes don't say that
it's true I know how you feel mistress I
took away your most beloved of course
you could hate me but you are very kind
to show me such compassion Maria can you
stand mistress let's get out of here
together but mistress I'm the same as
you aria
I can't live without father's love but
if father doesn't want us we've been
abandoned we have to live without him
now even though you and I can't live in
alone
so we'll help each other to keep living
even if father Scout mistress
I shall accompany you yes as a walking
Oh that I get each other
apologies mistress but I should could I
have your shoulder yes that is the
cutest little thing they are what look
we're going together left right left
right left right up and then dives this
is definitely different
yeah Oh shed father mister sorry Koko
need okay oh sure
Maria no we're living together we're not
leaving you behind
I can't go any farther you must escape
alone mistress
it can't be it is fine I shall not leave
you alone I will follow behind for sure
believe me please Maria oh oh no I don't
want to leave her come on hey come on
what a little [ __ ] croc gun it shall be
the last time I save on you oh oh
oh no all right work what's gonna change
now what oh [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] creepy
that doll hey come with us nah but it's
weird cuz all the other dolls wanted to
help her in a sense
I don't know wait maybe not all of them
that's enough of your game of argument a
guy yeah I have to keep you still don't
I let's go
I didn't wanna hurt you I yeah it's a
shame
no stop father but I can cover your leg
with a skirt easily enough so it should
be fine I don't want this I wanted to
stay with father I'll be father some
place
stop this oh yeah don't worry father and
I will always be together now so rest in
peace I am I'll be well this should
happen oh yes yeah whoa she throat three
knives and once that's pretty badass
ah yeah father I love ya
more knife fighter
Maria you came whoa
she's badass mistress hurry yeah
you heart sniff oh yeah ah father isn't
moving the father died I apologize I had
no other choice left to protect you
I guess it's for the best right mom
she call her mama what what guys crazy
oh he came I was like what the hell was
up with that guy you never come anyway
nice going it's me
I'm glad I made it triple dad so that
was it
okay fine
I like designing better so far I don't
know it's weird it's not wrestle like
who's Slenderman it still don't really
know everything but I hope some things
will be Oh we picked snowball with us no
need to Thanks I just did what she asked
you mean mom yes I said I was sorry for
scaring you and intend to get injured
believe that at least I understand mom
wanted to protect me thank you mom
I want to see you again she wanted that
too but I don't think she wanted to be
seen as she is now that's whatever mom
looks like Edie it's alright
she's watching you from afar so don't be
sad if you are it will only make her sad
right
the curves will wear off soon so it's
almost very well you'll go away we're
all alive now only because of the cure
curse I see but there's something I must
do before I go and that is to set fire
on them at this mansion why would you
you can't do that all those memories are
being happy it's not my intent to burn
those but it's possible that someone
could find traces of your father here we
can't let the trace tragedy have the
same tried to happen again if that one
mom wanted to I guess
okay if that's what mom wanted then do
it
mistress it's okay Maria everything's I
was gone my members of father mom Wonka
mistress that well you can [ __ ] say
yes that's right
oh yeah there's one thing I ask of you
do not ever forget the people who were
sacrificed here none of us had any
relatives no one looked for us no one
remembered us
no one knew we existed at all our
existence will be forgotten to the world
but we did intend indeed lab so I don't
want you want you to forget that I want
you to help proof in your heart that we
were here that is at least you can do
for us fine yeah I'll never forget thank
you well this is goodbye oh I wanted
them to stay together I mean you could
do some plastic surgery without I thing
and ah yeah may you I put the charm on
her bad luck gout that I found you
now go goddamn I'm dramatic
that's how we get all the ladies goodbye
come star ball
let's party
ah
why is he going
ah no he's like
haha others unmanned humans are such
hardly foolish creatures I've seen
countless many foolish humans but you
are the most foolish of them all a human
mad with desire is more fearsome than
any demon and yet I adore such foolish
humans come to me come to me and you may
research to your heart's content I guess
he doesn't have much of a choice is it
it's just the two of us now yeah
snowball
haha that's yeah that's right
I should be there now I don't know we
have to find somewhere to live but I'm
sure I can't live alone Maria will you
come with me
yes of course you have taught me so much
mistress now it is the time for me to
help you whatever awaits us ahead I wish
to protect you all the way thank you
let's go are you sure whether I was
watching to the end yeah it's fine
actually I wonder where that guy with a
black coat when I kind of hope he's okay
don't worry about it you got snowball
cheston's right though he's a really
strange guy come on snowball father
mother goodbye it's not a book is that
the diary a book
mistress
that's how what is it nothing let's go
what the mistress is very hearty even
after that harsh experience she walks on
without shedding a tear however what is
his uneasiness I feel doctor he's still
alive somewhere oh Jesus
finally here so that's the mistress
right what about this place now is this
a customer drevis dream is clinic clinic
yeah that must be the place it's in the
middle of nowhere no one would even
notice but it's out cow
you got barrels though I don't know what
I feel about hey nyah
uh hello oh she has short hair now ah a
patient welcome she's so pretty
is she the doctor what seems to be the
problem
yes well I was born rather feeble I've
asked my local doctor for a checkup but
how do I say this my family's really
poor so the doctors given up on me
that's why I came here
I heard the doctor here does checkups
for free yes we don't ask any money from
our patients so don't worry really
I always don't have any so I can really
get examined of course thank thank you
so much what a lovely little ayah what's
your name I'm Jean Jean Rooney Jean wow
that's a wonderful name I'm I a dream
it's nice to meet you Jean yeah you too
aha it doesn't sound good we should
examine you right away come in come in
considering you're not all that healthy
your legs
sure carried you a long way what is it
was it difficult for you I'm addict an
old woman on the way here she told me a
part that's probably the mistress or not
marry Ami
it was
nice away there are some really nice
people out of here just like you dr.
Treves hey thanks
now lie down here boy I'm nervous it's
not a horse
I hear horses they don't sound far off
are they in the back stay very still
while I apply anaesthesia Dyess you have
very pretty eyes you know ah so
beautiful I can't stop looking at them
no one said that to me before thank you
very much
hey nervous huh it's fine just relax
your shoulder
doctor I'm doctor do you think you can
make me feel better
of course from now on you will never
suffer again so take it easy and go to
sleep
oh there's Maria sorry about the mouse
there
there's a diary again indeed the
mistress is much like here it does it
does run in the family no doctor so she
she keep out look at the boobs so she
may dad she become just like her dad I
guess
goddamnit alright that was the mad
father to rid the true ending it's still
kind of like a bad ending even though
it's the real ending but that's the
typical that's how horror ending should
be in my opinion I think we should wait
through the credits I don't think there
are too many anyway but yeah that was
actually worth the the replay or
whatever all this [ __ ] I did it was a
good ending edit not good ending but it
was a was a good ending you know what
I'm talking about don't be like dad why
am i overlying it I don't even know how
to name them I've been told that there
supposed to be a cutscene maybe after
the credits I think it depending on if
you got all the gems or not I don't
think I got all the games to be fully
honest I was kind of I don't know we'll
see let's see I could have gotten all of
them I could not have gotten all them
[ __ ] nose
I see
you
thank you for watching birds like a
division joy so gonna hook up my Braille
today and I'll see you next episode
about me
hi bro I'm trying got dog dr. Pratt got
ya what put it on our nail that badge Oh
Robert you're gonna live now my fingers
rub it ah